more than 250 million people live in a
country
other than the one they were born in in
other words they're immigrants
and dear viewer this number it doesn't
stop growing
in the last 50 years it has multiplied
by three and only since the year 2000
the number of immigrants has increased
by 80 million that's 80 million more
people who've left
their country in search of a better life
we are the dreamers of usa
[Music]
and as you can imagine most of the
world's immigrants more than 65 percent
have settled in the richest countries
such as the united states germany
australia and canada
[Music]
[Applause]
and it is precisely this fact that is
feeding all over the world controversial
furious and bitter debates on
immigration
and the discourse of many populist
movements
in recent years in europe for example
we've seen a lot of populist and
xenophobic parties emerging which have
targeted
immigration directly
you've certainly heard it all what if
they steal our jobs put us in danger
destroy our national identity
etc etc etc but perhaps the most
outstanding case of all of this is
donald trump he's made it very clear
that he is a president who really
doesn't like immigration
except yenno under really certain
circumstances
president trump barked at an immigration
deal that would include protections for
people from
haiti and some nations in africa
demanding to know
why he should accept immigrants from
quote
whole countries rather than from places
like norway
why on earth would trump think that
norwegians want to emigrate on
mass to the united states when they are
already richer than americans
in fact more people are moving from the
u.s to norway than
the other way around but let us not
stray too far from today's topic because
what we're really looking at today is
whether immigration is actually a danger
is it a
burden on society we want to look at
whether the united states is losing
economic momentum
because of all the immigrants that are
coming into the country we want to look
at whether the u.s
should stop the arrival of more
foreigners
so let's dive in
[Applause]
[Music]
now if there is one thing that we can
all agree on it's that we live in an
increasingly interconnected world that
is a world where it's becoming easier
faster and cheaper to go from one place
to another
and it's also a world where it's easier
to connect with our loved ones no matter
where they are
and as you can imagine all of these
things make the decision to
pack up and move to another country much
much easier that's why if there were 90
million immigrants around the world
in the 60s today there are more than 250
million
and you know what we can only expect
this number to grow
strongly in the upcoming years first
it's because it's becoming easier to
move and
second because of the huge demographic
growth that many poor countries
are experiencing so dear viewer the real
question that we want to get back to
is is there a reason to worry well
listen up
[Music]
a lucky break
whenever rich countries talk about
immigration it sounds like they're
debating whether or not
to engage in some sort of charity and
you know what
nothing could actually be further from
the truth here immigration
favors economic growth among other
things because most immigrants
are adults of working age
[Music]
therefore it's been calculated that
since the year 2000 immigrants have been
responsible for
40 to 80 percent of their main recipient
country's workforce growth
so let's be honest without them these
countries
they'd be far less wealthy
but yes i know this is all very
abstract if you want to see exactly how
this happened in one of the countries
where immigration has caused a lot of
controversy well let's have a look at
the united kingdom
in recent years while some political
groups warned about the enormous threat
that immigration
including immigrants coming from other
european countries posed for british
jobs identity and way of life the truth
is
that the economy has placed very very
different numbers
on the table
[Music]
never before in history have so many
people been employed in the united
kingdom as there are today
neither in absolute or relative terms
and it doesn't even matter if we exclude
immigrants here
never before as the british population
had as many job opportunities as they do
right now and not only that according to
studies from several british
universities
all these immigrants pay more taxes than
they get in benefits from the state and
if that weren't enough the uk is
managing to attract
more university immigrants than any
other european country
in other words the effect of this
immigration is very
very positive for the british and it's
also helping turn the united kingdom
into a technological
powerhouse not bad right well you know
what despite
trump's fiery speeches the truth is that
on the other side of the pond
things aren't really any different
listen to this
the north american dream
with just over 44 million people which
is more or less the population of spain
the united states is in absolute terms
the country
with the most immigrants in the world
[Music]
however wait just a moment because in
relative terms things are rather
different
these 44 million people represent just
under
14 of the entire population to give you
a better idea here in countries like
australia or new zealand for example the
percentage is almost
twice as high
now here is a big question for you and
please don't cheat and google it what
impact do you think immigration
has had on the united states well dear
viewer listen up
despite representing just under 14 of
the population
immigrants are responsible for almost 25
percent of all businesses that open in
the united states they're also
responsible for more than 30
of the companies in which venture
capital funds invest and almost
half of all silicon valley high-tech
startups
are started by immigrants and that's not
all here according to a study from the
center for american entrepreneurship 43
of the 500 largest companies in the
united states were founded either by
immigrants or the children of immigrants
fine
yes i'd love to three weeks ago we
bought another ford
the new low price custom line victoria
that's 216 companies whose revenues
surpass
5 trillion every year and employ almost
13 million people all around the world
we're talking about nearly half of the
great us economic powerhouse
from henry ford to elon musk many of the
great figures and iconic characters of
the united states
they weren't even born in that country
[Music]
now hold on just a moment because i bet
some of you are probably thinking right
now well
okay simon but those are only a few
immigrants the most
educated ones i mean what about all of
the rest simon
[Music]
well the truth is that the numbers they
don't very much hear either
their entrepreneurship and employment
rates are also really high
and by the way they also provide several
other benefits for example in a country
that at the moment has pretty much full
employment
new immigrants reinforce the us's
competitiveness
encourage the rest of the american
population to do more and allow for many
businesses that would have otherwise not
existed
to be created
so in summary immigrants reduce the
population's average age they have more
children are more educated and more
enterprising they far more patents
and well the list it goes on and if you
think about it for a second
it does make a lot of sense on the one
hand these people arrive to achieve a
better future so they're willing to take
risks and
work really hard now on the other hand
they've had different experiences
and education and they can take
advantage of this
in order to progress think for example
of italian pizzas or mexican tacos that
flood the u.s today
as well as the rest of the world well
despite these arguments
and the fact that never before have so
many americans had jobs
politicians like donald trump still
don't like
immigration but you know what this isn't
the first time that the u.s political
leaders have spoken out against
immigration it has become
the issue in the governor's race pete
wilson a 187 supporter
is pinning his re-election hopes on
anti-immigrant sentiments
[Music]
the precedence
dear viewer this is by no means that the
united states the
country of immigrants has had political
campaigns against them
you see in the middle of the 19th
century the political movement no
nothing opposed immigration particularly
from the irish
and soon after they focused on the
chinese yep you heard that right they
were focusing on the chinese
during the second half of the 19th
century many chinese came to the united
states and that triggered
a rather hostile popular reaction
from seattle to los angeles from wyoming
to the small towns of california
immigrants from china were forced out of
business
run out of town beaten tortured lynched
and massacred
usually with little hope of help from
the law immigration
work from the library of congress all
this because at that time americans
saw the chinese as the competition
and in 1882 the federal congress itself
approved the law of exclusion of the
chinese which not only suspended the
arrival of new chinese immigrants but
also made the lives of those who were
already in the u.s
rather complicated and that wasn't all
in 1924 after around 30 million people
had crossed the atlantic ocean to reach
the u.s
washington established a quota policy
that greatly reduced the number of
immigrants that could arrive
and they also vetoed immigrants from
southern europe such as spain and italy
as well as eastern europe asia and
africa
so basically the few who could enter
they had to be anglo-saxons
[Music]
and more recently in 1994 the then
governor of california pete wilson
blamed hispanic immigrants for the
state's poor
economic situation and you want to know
what he did well he launched a
huge political campaign against
immigration and pushed the so-called
proposition 187
a law that prevented access to social
educational and
even health services for all illegal
immigrants
and yes this included children it was so
aggressive
that just a year later the supreme court
declared it unconstitutional
we are going to take back california for
the working
tax paying families of this state
the fact is that despite all these
campaigns against immigration
existing research shows that states and
counties that
historically had more immigration now
have a higher income
less poverty less unemployment and
better educational results so with all
this data in mind it might be good for
both the white house and the capital to
focus less on how to deport people
and more on how to strengthen access and
try to approve once and for all
a migratory reform that facilitates the
orderly arrival of more people
more workers more entrepreneurs and more
researchers
all of this would greatly aid the north
american economy by the way in a future
video which we'll try to make available
very soon for our patreon page and later
here on this channel we're going to
discuss the
great myths that exist about immigration
but now well it's your turn do you think
your country should
reduce the entry of immigrants or should
they increase it well leave your answer
in the comments below as well as in this
survey and i really hope you enjoyed
this video please do hit that like
button if you did and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new
videos
don't forget to check out our friends at
the reconsider media podcast they
provided the vocals in this episode that
were not mine
and as always thank you for watching it
has become the
issue in the governor's race pete wilson
a 187 supporter
is pinning his re-election hopes on
anti-immigrant sentiment
you